[Musik]
und jetzt das heute journal mit Hanna
Zimmermann und Christian Siebers ihn
allen guten Abend wir sind mitten in
einem Krieg der viele Grenzen verwischt
und überschreitet ein Krieg der im Nahen
Osten tobt aber große Teile dieser Welt
erreicht in den sogenannten sozialen
Medien wünschen sich wildfremde Menschen
gegenseitig den Tod auf den Straßen
wütende Proteste ohne einen Augenblick
des innerhaltens wohin man guckt kaum
noch Bereitschaft die Argumente und den
Blickwinkel der anderen auch nur
wahrzunehmen und das gilt für alle
Seiten dabei ist man mit Schwarz und
Weiß gerade in Nahost noch nie
weitergekommen kaum eine Region ist so
von Grautönen von mehr und
Uneindeutigkeit geprägt wie diese es
gibt den alten korrespondentenpruch je
mehr man erfährt desto weniger versteht
man wir beginnen unsere
Berichterstattung heute Abend mit der
Lage vor Ort in Gaza wo israels
Regierung Feuerpausen ablehnt und der
Verteidigungsminister heute sagt jeder
in gazastadt riskiere sein Leben aus Tel
Aviv berichtet Henriette
deier Schritt für Schritt dringen
israelische Soldaten den Gazastreifen
vor Bilder des israelischen Militärs die
den Erfolg zeigen
sollen heute haben die israelischen
Streitkräfte unter der Führung der
golani Spezialeinheiten die Stadt Gaza
umzingelt sie sind südlich der Stadt bis
zum Meer vorgestoßen de facto ist der
Gazastreifen seit heute in Gaza Nord und
Gaza Süd geteilt auch die Angriffe aus
der Luft gehen unvermindert weiter unser
Team in Gaza filmte diese Bilder laut
Angaben der Hamas starben in der
vergangenen Nacht mindestens 38 Menschen
bei einem Angriff auf ein
flüchtlingsviertel wir suchen unter den
Trümmern nach Familien und Kindern wir
haben vor kurzem eine Leiche
herausgeholt gestern waren wir wie immer
auf der Straße und als es dunkel
geworden ist und wir keinen Strom hatten
kehrten wir nach Hause zurück und
plötzlich
Explosion kam plötzlich die Menschen
wurden nicht aufgefordert ihre Häuser zu
verlassen sie wurden plötzlich gegen
22:30 Uhr nachts mit einer Rakete
bombardiert weitermachen bis wir sie
besiegen beschwor israels
Ministerpräsident Netanyahu heute
Soldaten bei einem Truppenbesuch er
sagte wir haben keine
Wahl ich möchte euch eindeutig sagen was
wir nicht tun werden es wird keine
Waffenpause geben ohne die Rückkehr der
entführten das kann man gleich streichen
wir sagen das sowohl unseren Feinden als
auch unseren Freunden und spielt damit
auf US Außenminister blinken an der
heute in ramala war und mit
Palästinenser Präsident Abbas
zusammentraf Abbas fordert eine
sofortige Waffenruhe blinken lehnt dies
als Stärkung der Hamas ab setzt sich für
örtlich begrenzte Kampfpausen
ein währenddessen protestieren in ramala
die Menschen werfen den USA vor blind zu
unterstützen blinken inzwischen in den
Irak weitergereist stellt Überlegungen
für die Zukunft
an bei der Gestaltung der Zukunft für
das Westjordanland und für den
Gazastreifen und letztlich für einen
palästinensischen Staat müssen die
palästinensischen Stimmen im Mittelpunkt
stehen die Palästinensische
Autonomiebehörde ist der Repräsentant
dieser Stimmen und deshalb ist es
wichtig dass Sie eine führende Rolle
spielt
es ist eine rastlose Diplomatie in einem
Konflikt der täglich mehr Opfer fordert
auf beiden Seiten ja pendeld diipomatie
ist das was der usaußenminister da macht
pendeldiplomatie im Angesicht des
Krieges erst tellaviv dann Aman
Jordanien heute ramala die heimliche
Hauptstadt der Palästinenser im
Westjordanland wo er deren Präsident
Mahmud Abbas traf Elm tisson beobachtet
das Ganze für uns aus Washington Elm das
ist eine Mission bei der blinken
zunehmend müder aussieht was hat er denn
bisher wirklich
erreicht also eigentlich nur eins er hat
glaube ich allen glaubhaft vermittelt
dass die USA mit aller militärischer
Macht gegen jeden vorgehen wollen der
eine zweite Front gegen Israel eröffnen
will das ist natürlich vor allen auf den
Iran gemünzt aber in allem anderen muss
ich Tony blinken eigentlich vorkommen
ich sag mal wie ein Handelsvertreter dem
man eigentlich nicht glaubt denn er hat
aus Israel von seinen Gesprächen nichts
mitbringen könnten was was nur
ansatzweise wie eine Unterstützung für
eine Zweistaatenlösung beispielsweise
aussieht er redet von Feuerpausen er
redet von mehr Schutz für die zivilen
für die Zivilisten in Gazastreifen aber
sagt gleichzeitig die USA könnten nicht
mehr als Ratschläge geben und deswegen
wirkt es für seine Gesprächspartner
eigentlich auch sehr unglaubwürdig wenn
er sagt und auch verspricht dass wenn
Israel Vorhaben sollte alle
Palästinenser aus dem Gazastreifen zu
verteil zu vertreiben dass die USA dies
verhindern würden also insgesamt hat er
Schwierigkeiten seine Positionen in der
Region anzubringen jetzt hatte sich ja
sein Chef US-Präsident Biden selbst
immer wieder auf die Fahnen geschrieben
dass er es erreicht habe dass das
Handynetz zumindest in Gaza weiter
funktioniert und auch wieder
funktioniert jetzt sehen wir aber ganz
aktuell das Telefon und Internet in Gaza
heute wieder komplett ausgefallen sind
israel habe jedes Recht sich selbst zu
verteidigen aber das wie sei
entscheidend hören wir immer wieder aus
Amerika haben denn die Amerikaner den
Eindruck dass sie tatsächlich auch
gehört werden von Netanyahu in
Jerusalem genau den Eindruck haben sie
eben nicht Washington Post und New York
Times Berichten hier unter Berufung auf
Regierungskreise dass man im Weißen Haus
tief frustriert ist und zum einen über
das Wie des Vorgehens also dass Israel
beispielsweise 1000 2000 Pfund schwere
Bomben einsetzt ob eben die hamasführung
auszuschalten aber dabei eben sehr viele
Zivilisten trifft das könnte vielleicht
etwas besser sein wenn man nur 250 Pfund
Bomben einsetzen würde dann wäre man
genauso effektiv so heißt es hier in
Washington aber könnte eine mögliche
Eskalation in der Region durch die hohen
Opferzahlen vermeiden und das zweite ist
man will eigentlich eine Antwort auf die
Frage aus Israel haben was ist denn das
Endgame also wie soll der Plan Aussehen
für ein Gaza nach der Vernichtung der
Heras dem Ziel der Vernichtung dem
stimmen die USA 100% zu aber wie soll es
danach weitergehen und das scheint das
bisher bei Netanyahu nicht
durchzudringen blinken hat ja überall
gesagt es braucht eine Vision für eine
Zukunft auch der Palästinenser und
Israels damit Israel langfristig in
Sicherheit leben kann Elma vielen Dank
für diese Analyse aus
Washington und dann natürlich auch heute
der Blick nach Israel dort immer noch
bangen um die Geiseln in der Hand von
Hamas Trauer um die Toten nach dem
beispiellosen Massaker vom 7 Oktober und
Furcht davor was noch kommen mag aber
auch Entschlossenheit den Kampf gegen
Hamas durchzuziehen Katrin Eigendorf
berichtet noch immer hängt die Schwere
und Stille über Tel Aviv die Stadt die
sich sonst feiert für ihre Leichtigkeit
und das Leben hat noch nicht
zurückgefunden in den
Alltag für Arthur raschkovan hat sich
alles verändert in seiner surfchule
bietet er jetzt Kurse für traumatisierte
israelische Kinder an juditth die mit
ihren a Kindern aus askelon im Süden
Israels fliehen musste ist dankbar für
die
Unterstützung für viele Kinder ist es
das erste Mal dass sie den Schrecken
vergessen das Surfen eine Therapie sein
kann weiß Arthur aus langjähriger
Erfahrung über 20 Jahre lang hat er mit
Kindern aus Gaza gearbeitet seit dem 7
Oktober glaubt er nicht mehr an ein
friedliches
Zusammenleben das ist das was die Leute
nicht verstehen und nicht sehen dass wir
so leben du musst verstehen wie
beängstigend es gerade
ist der Museumsplatz von Tel Aviv ist zu
einem Mahnmal geworden das Schicksal der
241 Menschen die von Hamas Terroristen
verschleppt wurden bewegt die Israelis
jeden einzelnen zurückzubringen hinter
diesem Ziel hat sich ein ganzes Land
vereint und die Angehörigen der Geiseln
sind zu einer wichtigen politischen
Stimme geworden auch ihre Unterstützer v
es darf keine Feuerpause mit der Hamas
geben solange Israel keinen Zugang zu
den Verschleppten
erhält Israel tut wirklich alles was es
kann um nicht unschuldige Bürger zu
verletzen nicht Kinder zu verletzen
nicht Babys zu verletzen wir sind nicht
die Monster in der Geschichte wir
versuchen wirklich alles um sie zu
beschützen mehr als Hamas das
tut wie sehr sich Israel verändert ist
dort spürbar wo Juden und Araber
zusammen
sind viele der Geschäfte noch
geschlossen das gegenseitige Misstrauen
ist groß viele Israelis meiden
jafosstraßen bei Abu Hassan einem der
bekanntesten arabischen Restaurants
machen sie sich Sorgen um die Zukunft
die Familie kaavan stammt aus Gaza sie
leben in dritter Generation in jaffoalil
ist in Israel geboren und hat einen
israelischen Pass er ist gegen den
krieging oder irgendeine Verbesserung
Menschen werden getötet Kinder aber auch
Männer das wird Auswirkungen auf die
künftige Generation
haben wie soll Israels Zukunft aussehen
eine Frage die das ganze Land bewegt und
auch verunsichert wirkliche Antworten
haben sie noch
nicht gucken wir jetzt auf mögliche
Antworten mit Tom Segev er ist einer der
renommiertesten Historiker Israels er
hat mehrere Standardwerke verfasst zur
Geschichte es Landes und ist jetzt live
bei uns guten Abend nach
Jerusalem guten Abend Ihnen auch her SEG
kann ich Ihnen vielleicht die
schwierigste Frage gleich zu allererst
stellen wie kommen wir einer Lösung
näher sehen Sie dafür einen Plan oder
ist aus israelischer Sicht im Moment
einfach noch nicht die Zeit
dafür also man fängt mit dem
Notwendigsten an das Notwendigste für
heute Abend morgen früh übermorgen ist
die Befreiung der
der der Gefangenen da die die die
Geiseln das sind Leute die man kennt
also Leute die überhaupt nichts zu tun
haben mit mit Frieden oder oder Krieg
oder sonst was das sind
alte Leute Kinder Babys auch die die
halten die chamas schon ewig ich glaube
das allererste was dafür zu sorgen ist
ist dass die dass die Geiseln befreit
werden
gleichzeitig ist es notwendig ich den
Palästinensern
ähm humanitäre Hilfe
äh zu bringen und
äh es kann bestimmt keine Lösung sein
äh solange die Hamas noch irgendwas zu
sagen hat in in Gaza
äh Israel kämpft zwar gegen die Hamas es
ist aber wichtig glaube ich wenn sie
sich überhaupt so historisch ein
bisschen interessieren ist istor ist ist
wichtig zu sagen dass äh ist den
Palästinensern in Gaza viel viel besser
gingen würde wenn sie nicht von der
Hamas beherrscht werden das ist eine
totalitäre äh sehr sehr extremistische
äh Bewegung die die die Menschen das
Leben
vurchtbar verdorben hat eigentlich ganze
Generationen von Menschen in Gaza israel
hat auch eine Schuld daran aber die
Hamas bestimmt auch her segf kann also
ohne Hamas geht's den Palästinensern
auch besser Herr segerf kann man Hamas
als Terrororganisation sicherlich
ausschalten gegen Ideologie in den
Köpfen kommen aber Soldaten ja nicht an
deswegen die Frage wie viel Raum ist
denn konkret für für etwas was
nachheramas dann kommen soll gibt es da
eine konkrete Idee in
Israel ich glaube nicht es gibt mehrere
Ideen es gibt jede Zahl von Professoren
die im Fernsehen darüber sprechen aber
ich glaube dass in der Regierung es
überhaupt keine Idee gibt was da
passieren soll oder vielleicht genauer
gesagt
ähm viele Ideen
es ist äh im Moment noch schwer
überhaupt zu unterscheiden was Israel
eigentlich will in in Gaza ist ist noch
schwer zu unterscheiden zwischen ähm Wut
und und Rache und und und Schock und
strategisches Denken
ähm ist ist schwer zu unterscheiden mhm
sie haben vor zwei Wochen mit uns
gesprochen und damals haben sie gesagt
über den Schock in Israel nach dem
Massaker vom 7 Oktober wir sind nicht so
stark wie wir dachten wir werden unsere
Identität neu formulieren müssen das
sind Sätze die ich nicht mehr vergessen
habe seitdem weil sie so grundsätzlich
sind sind sie denn mittlerweile
weitergekommen bei dieser Formulierung
einer neuen
Identität noch nicht es wir wir sind
alle noch schockiert ich bin bin selber
noch noch wirklich schockiert und
die Idee dass es gibt eine ganze
Generation von Israelis die aufgewachsen
ist mit der Idee dass sowas nicht
passieren kann dass dass da irgendwelche
Terroristen kommen und 2000 Menschen in
ihren Betten
umbringen das kann ja gar nicht
passieren wir sind eine Hightech
Großmacht die jedes Gespräch in Gaza
abhören kann und ähm ich glaube dass wir
neu denken müssen auch über unsere
Identität äh wir hatten äh gerade in den
letzten Monaten eine sehr große
starke Debatten über über über
Grundwerte dieses Staates dieser
Gesellschaft und
ich glaube dass
es vielleicht Zeit ist dass wir doch
wieder anfangen daran zu denken wie wir
mit den Palästinensern leben können
eines der Sachen die Netanyahu gemacht
hat in den letzten Jahren war den
Israelis die zu geben dass die
palästinensisches Problem eigentlich
unter Kontrolle steht es ist alles in
Ordnung und ich glaube dass wenigstens
damit man man
jetzt nicht mehr fertig werden kann das
eben nicht alles in Ordnung ist und man
tatsächlich jetzt wieder auf die
Palästinenser auch noch mehr zugehen
müsste ist es das was sie
raten es ist ein Konflikt der seit über
100 Jahren nicht gelöst werden kann er
kann nur gemanaged werden und ich glaube
dass in den letzten 100 Jahren er noch
nie so katastrophal gemanaged wurde wie
unter Netanyahu das heißt es gibt noch
vieles was man was man anders machen
kann ja es gibt vieles was man äh mit
den mit den mit den Palästinensern
machen kann um irgendwelches
Zusammenleben befreundet werden wir
nicht sein zusammen in einem Staat
werden wir nicht leben die zwei
staatenlösung äh sehe ich auch nicht
kommen ich glaube das ist eine
diplomatische Fiktion die alle Länder
sich angeeignet haben um irgendwie die
Hoffnung für Frieden zu zu erhalten aber
ähm ich dachte manchmal so im stillen
wenn ich das wagte dass irgendwie ein
eine große Katastrophe eine tektonische
Katastrophe von biblischen ausmäßen
notwendig ist um uns dazu zu bringen
sowohl die Palästinenser als wir um neu
zu denken ich weiß nicht ob das jetzt
der Fall ist aber äh ich bin eigentlich
ziemlich pessimistisch und jetzt durch
diesen Krieg überhaupt ich habe vier
kleine Enkelkinder die jede Nacht in ihr
Sicherheitsraum müssen
ja es ist keine schöne Zeit und sie wird
noch immer schlimmer und bei den
Palästinensern ist es noch schlimmer
weil die Palästinenser eigentlich eine
zweite NAB jetzt eben die nabar ist die
äh Tragödie der Palästinenser von
1948 ähm aber wissen Sie
ähm mein Vater ist umgekommen in dem
ersten Krieg von 1948 als ich 3 Jahre
alt war und ich lebe diesen Konflikt
seither eigentlich dauernd und äh ähm
kenne fast alles was irgendwer jemals
eine Idee gehabt hat
äh ich weiß es nicht ich bin einfach
sehr pessimistisch ein pessimistischer
und ratloser Historiker auch das sagt
viel über die aktuelle Situation Tom
segf ganz herzlichen Dank für das
Gespräch und Shalom nach
Jerusalem Shalom Ihnen auch danke
schön und jetzt Hanna du hast den
Überblick über weitere Nachrichten und
bleibst erstmal beim Thema ja ganz genau
in der Türkei ist es nahe des US
luftwaffenstützpunkts in inelig zu
Auseinandersetzungen zwischen der
Polizei und propalästinensischen
Demonstranten gekommen nachdem einige
protestierende versucht haben sollen den
Stützpunkt zu stürmen
proalästinensische Proteste gab es auch
in der indonesischen Hauptstadt Jakarta
und im pakistanischen Islamabad hier
forderten 10tausende ein Ende der
Angriffe Israels auf den Gazastreifen
auch in Griechenland wurde demonstriert
dort zogen die Protestierenden vor das
Parlament in
Athen nach dem Austritt SAR wagenknechts
will sich die Linke strategisch neu
aufstellen die Parteispitze hat dazu
heute ein Positionspapier verabschiedet
darin vorgesehen ist unter anderem ein
klimageld von 200 € pro Monat und zwar
für alle mit einem Bruttoeinkommen von
bis zu 4000 € monatlich eine vom Bund
finanzierte industriestiftung soll zudem
Anteile an wichtigen Unternehmen
erwerben und damit einen klimaneutralen
umbausteuern wenige Wochen vor Beginn
der Weltklimakonferenz in Dubai hat es
offenbar einen Durchbruch bei den
Verhandlungen über einen
klimaentschädigungsfond für ärmere
Länder gegeben laut
entwicklungsstaatssekretär flasbart habe
man sich auf eine Grundstruktur einigen
können ärmere Länder die besonders stark
vom Klimawandel betroffen sind aber
selbst kaum etwas dazu beitragen sollen
aus dem Fond finanzielle Unterstützung
erhalten der erarbeitete Vorschlag muss
noch von der Weltklimakonferenz
angenommen
werden nach den schweren Unwettern in
der italienischen Toscana ist die Region
in der vergangenen Nacht erneut von
Stürmen und Starkregen heimgesucht
worden etwa 1000 Menschen wurden in
Sicherheit gebracht in rund 16 000
Haushalten fiel der Strom aus mindestens
sieben Personen sind in Italien infolge
der Unwetter seit Donnerstagabend ums
Leben
gekommen so schnell zwischendurch dieser
Hinweis mit allen wichtigen Nachrichten
jederzeit aktuell hält sie natürlich die
ZDF heute App die jetzt ganz neu auch
bei Whatsapp App zu finden ist scannen
Sie dafür einfach den angezeigten
QR-Code oder abonnieren Sie uns dann
direkt bei Whatsapp selbst die
Nachrichtenlage kompakt zusammengefasst
mit den Updates am Morgen und am Abend
alles ganz einfach und auch dort würden
sie dann natürlich erfahren dass morgen
ein Tag in Deutschland anbricht mit
hohen finanziellen Erwartungen an eine
dauerhafte Neuregelung beim Thema
Migration wir erinnern uns Deutschlands
Flüchtlingspolitik ist ja das Thema das
zuletzt eine ganze Reihe von Wahlen mit
entschieden hatte morgen treffen sich
die regierungschefinnen und Chefs der 16
Bundesländer erst untereinander dann mit
dem Kanzler ein Scheitern der Gespräche
wäre der Bevölkerung wohl kaum zu
vermitteln andererseits sind die
jeweiligen Standpunkte und Forderungen
immer noch weit auseinander Christoph
Wiesel
erklärt wo früher einmal ein
Klassenzimmer war stehen jetzt die
Betten von morsen Rai und hasbullah S
seit vier Monaten sind die beiden jungen
Männer aus Afghanistan in dieser
Flüchtlingsunterkunft im Landkreis
Fürstenfeldbruck untergebracht als
Asylbewerber erhalten Sie hier
zusätzlich zur Unterbringung pro Monat
410 € in
bar wir können damit z.B Bahntickets
kaufen unser Essen
Kleidung bargeld ist besser weil wir
können wir können entscheiden was wir
kaufen wo kaufen wir dieses Dinge doch
laut sind sozeit stimmen die fordern
Geldleistungen an Asylbewerber
runterzufahren stattdessen auf
Sachleistungen zu setzen weniger Bargeld
gleich weniger Anreize gerade nach
Deutschland zu kommen davon ist etwa
Fürstenfeldbrucks Landrat überzeugt er
fordert einen Umstieg auf Bezahlkarten
mit denen Asylbewerber einkaufen aber
kein Geld in die Heimat überweisen
könnten dieses System brauche es
einheitlich in ganz
Deutschland zum einen sollte es keinen
Wettbewerb unter den Kommunen geben wer
der attraktivste ist oder unattraktivste
oder wie auch immer äh zum anderen ist
es technisch natürlich sinnvoll wenn Sie
es etwa über den Sparkassenverband oder
über ein
Bankinstitut so regeln und zum dritten
wäre es natürlich auch ein Zeichen nach
außen in Deutschland wird es jetzt so
praktiziert und das wäre sicher sinnvoll
ein mögliches Zeichen nach außen über
das morgen auch in Berlin diskutiert
wird Bund ländergipfel dominiert von der
Frage wie die Kontrolle zurückgewinnen
über die Migration Forderungen liegen zu
genüge auf dem Tisch ein
Beschlussvorschlag ebenfalls der nennt
etwa das Fortsetzen der Grenzkontrollen
schnellere Asyl fahren und eben auch das
Thema Bezahlkarten schrittig aber wer
verantwortlich ist es ist ja heute schon
möglich mit der shipkarte zu arbeiten
also von bargeldleistung auf
Sachleistung umzustellen das gibt es
schon seit einiger Zeit das können die
Länder die Landkreise machen und ich bin
dafür dass da morgen ganz pragmatisch
drüber geredet wird ob man das ganze
ausweiten kann und sogar zu
bundeseinheitlichen Modellen kommen wie
weit der willlle zur Einigung reicht
dürfte sich aber besonders bei einem
anderen Thema zeigen Bund und Länder
Ringen darum wie sie sich die Kosten für
Unterbringung und Versorgung der
Asylbewerber aufteilen auch morgen ist
der Streit
vorprogrammiert der Bund hat den
Schlüssel zur Steuerung und Begrenzung
der Zuwanderung in der Hand deswegen
kann er darüber bestimmen wie viele
kommen und wie viele nicht und deswegen
brauchen wir ein atmes System je mehr
kommen desto mehr muss der Bund sich
beteiligen und je weniger kommen und er
hat s ja in der Hand desto weniger muss
er zahlen das es morgen konkrete
Ergebnisse braucht da sind sich alle
einig was die Beschlüsse wert sind
darauf wird man auch in den Kommunen
ganz genau
schauen am Hamburger Flughafen ist der
Betrieb wieder angelaufen als erste
Maschine landete einer aus Hannover dort
warum ist sowas eine Nachricht weil der
Airport über viele Stunden gesperrt war
weil dort ein Mann seit gestern Abend
seine Tochter als Geisel festgehalten
hatte und sofor mit dem Auto das Tor zum
Sicherheitsbereich auf dem Vorfeld
durchbrochen hatte wie ist sowas möglich
zumal es am Hamburger Flughafen gerade
erst schon mal passiert ist dass
Unbefugte aufs Vorfeld kamen die
Geiselnahme ist heute Mittag glimpflig
zu Ende gegangen die Fragen aber bleiben
Petra Meer Hamburg Airport heute kurz
nach 2R der Geiselnehmer am Boden seine
vierjährige Tochter steht vor ihm
widerstandslos lässt der Mann zu dass
eine Polizistin das Kind fortbringt
zuvor hatten beideer 18 Stunden in
diesem Auto verbracht ja das Kind ist
von uns in ophut genommen worden und den
ersten Eindruck den wir jetzt hatten ist
dass das Kind ganz gut drauf ist gestern
gegen 20 Uhr durchbricht der 35-jährige
Mann mit seinem Fahrzeug diese Schranke
fährt auf das Flughafengelände in
Hamburg schießt in die Luft und wirft
zwei Brandsätze neben einem Flugzeug aus
dem Fenster die Flughafenfeuerwehr
löscht sofort daraufhin fährt der
Geiselnehmer zu einem Flugzeug von
Turkish Airlines das gerade starten will
der Hamburg Airport wird evakuiert
Bundespolizei und Spezialeinsatzkräfte
übernehmen verhandeln mit dem
aufgebrachten Geiselnehmer der wohl
wegen eines Sorgerechtsstreits mit dem
Kind in die Türkei fliehen will um kurz
nach 2R heute mittag gibt er schließlich
auf wird vorläufig festgenommen der
Nervenkrieg hat ein Ende die Frage wie
der Geiselnehmer die
Sicherheitsvorkehrungen am Hamburger
Flughafen so einfach überwinden konnte
wird lauter wir reden hier von
kritischer Infrastruktur von einem
Flughafen wir müssen hier eine
lückenlose Überwachung der außenzäune
wir müssen Bewegungsmelder installieren
und es müssen natürlich auch Schranken
Barrieren aufgebaut werden die mit einem
normalen PKW nicht zu durchbrechen oder
zu durchfahren sind bereits im Juli war
es sogenannten klimaklebern gelungen
ungehindert mit Fahrrädern durch den
Sicherheitszaun auf das Rollfeld des
Hamburger Flughafen zu gelangen für die
Gewerkschaft der Polizei nicht
nachvollziehbar ich erkläre mir das
damit dass unsere gesetzlichen Vorgaben
die wir für kritische Infrastruktur
haben einfach nicht mehr Lage angepasst
und der Zeit angemessen sind und dass
hier der Gesetzgeber nachbessern muss
nach mehr als 20 stündigem Stillstand
müssen am Hamburg Airport jetzt gut
34.000 wartende Passagiere abgefertigt
und mehr als 300 Flüge nachgeholt werden
insgesamt ist der Betreiber aber nicht
unzufrieden mit dem
Krisenmanagement natürlich das ist kein
guter Tag für uns andererseits muss man
auch sagen wir haben gesehen dass die
Alarmkette so wie wir sie hatten nämlich
per Video und auch per Lichtschranke ist
Alarm ausgelöst worden Täter wurde
sofort geschnappt das ist für uns oder
tatsächlich lokalisiert auch eine
wichtige Erkenntnis der Flughafen kehrt
zurück in den Normalbetrieb am
Sicherheitskonzept muss noch gearbeitet
werden in der Fußballbundesliga gab es
heute zwei Begegnungen der VfL Wolfsburg
und Werder Bremen trennten sich
unentschieden 2:2 außerdem siegte der FC
Heidenheim gegen den VfB Stuttgart
entstand
2:0 Deutschland Handballer gehen mit
einem Erfolgserlebnis ins
europameisterschaftsjahr in der Münchner
Olympiahalle setzte sich die Mannschaft
von Trainer Alfred geslerson beim
zweiten Testspiel gegen afrikaameister
Ägypten knapp mit 28 Z 27 durch am
Freitag hatte sich hatten sich beide
Teams Unentschieden getrennt die EM
findet vom 10 bis 28 Januar 2024 in
Deutschland
statt diese Woche geht die Nächste kommt
und so auch unser traditioneller heute
journal Ausblick jetzt von Christian
[Musik]
Kirsch am Dienstag wird ein wichtiges
Urteil erwartet am
Bundesverwaltungsgericht in Leipzig die
Frage darf der Staat Schwerstkranken die
Herausgabe von tödlichen Medikamenten
verweigern zweimal waren die Kläger mit
ihrer Forderung gescheitert Zugang zu
bekommen zu dem tödlichen Medikament
jetzt die Entscheidung
den 9 November am Donnerstag nimmt der
Bundestag zum Anlass zu debattieren über
das Thema jüdisches Leben in Deutschland
Schützen am Jahrestag des prgroms im
Deutschen Reich ist das Problem
Antisemitismus in Deutschland derzeit
wieder sehr aktuell vor dem Hintergrund
zahlreicher Übergriffe seit den Attacken
der
Hamas ebenfalls am Donnerstag beginnen
die Verhandlungen im Tarifstreit
zwischen der Bahn und den lockführern
der GDL die Gewerkschaft stellt hohe
Forderungen die winkt ab Streiks noch
vor Weihnachten gelten als
wahrscheinlich am Sonntag wäre lorot 100
Jahre alt geworden der charmante Spötter
der Nation geboren 1923 in Brandenburg
an der hafel stellte Jahrzehnte lang
sicher dass auch in Deutschland gelacht
wurde Mobs Badewanne Nudel danke
lorot es geht uns hier nicht anders als
es ihnen möglicherweise geht geht die
Nachrichtenlage diese nicht abreißenden
Meldungen von Tod und Zerstörung in Gaza
und Israel von Wut und Hass von Hetze
und Erniedrigung auch bei uns
hinterlassen Spuren allein schon deshalb
können sie nicht alles sein was wir
Ihnen aus dieser Welt berichten hören
wir auf eine die erlebt hat was Menschen
imstande sind anderen Menschen
anzutun die Nazis haben ihre Mutter und
ihren Vater in Auschwitz ermordet ihren
Bruder auch
sie selbst hat das KZ und den Holocaust
überlebt und ist im hohen Alter zu uns
nach Deutschland zurückgekehrt um als
Zeitzeugin vor unzähligigen Schulklassen
in diesem Land zu berichten damit sich
Geschichte nicht wiederholt hören wir
auf maggort Friedländer die heute ihren
102 geburtstag feiert bin zurückgekommen
um mit euch zu sprechen euch die Hand zu
reichen aber euch zu zu bitten dass ihr
Zeugnis geben sollt wir können es nicht
mehr sehr lange machen wir sterben aus
ich sage immer es gibt kein christliches
kein jüdisches kein muslimisches Blut es
gibt nur menschliches
Blut herzlichen Glückwunsch zum
Geburtstag an ein großes zierliches
Vorbild sie habe nie gehasst sagt sie
sie würde nie hassen wollen es bringt
nichts ja und jetzt zum Wetter das
bleibt durchwachsen die Aussichten
morgen im Südosten länger sonnig sonst
wechselnd bewölkt im Norden später auch
im Südwesten häufiger Schauer örtlich
Gewitter lebhafter Südwestwind an der
See und im Bergland mit stürmischen
Böhen 9 bis 14° auch in den nächsten
Tagen wechselhaft mit einigen Schauern
vereinzelt Gewittern zwischendurch aber
auch mal länger freundlich Höchstwerte 7
bis
13° so wir zwei hier bedanken uns im
Namen des gesamten Teams für ihr
Interesse in dieser Woche durch die
kommende im heute journal begleiten Sie
Maria taslomka und Heinz Wolf einen
angenehmen Abend ihnen noch
tschüss